[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de salud en
directo américa y está conmigo en la
tierra no en el espacio ya más romeros a
la mar bienvenida feliz miércoles para
ti vamos a hablar de ahora sino que
hemos venido hablando durante todo
nuestro programa la gestión de la
pandemia de kobe 19 por parte del
presidente jair bolsonaro que está en
entredicho incluso el senado ya pues dio
luz verde para que empiecen un proceso
para juzgar a este presidente que
motivos médicos nomás hay detrás de
todas estas acusaciones pues los
primeros es la reticencia que tú voy a
ir bolsonaro a implementar las únicas
medidas que en ese momento sabíamos que
funcionaban contra la pandemia que eran
cuarentenas el distanciamiento social y
mascarillas y luego también ya después
de año y medio o más que llevamos de
crisis sanitaria una cierta reticencia a
confiar en evidencias médicas de
alrededor de las vacunas y de otros
medicamentos pero para hablar de todo
esto mucho mejor estamos con el doctor
oscar franco director del instituto de
medicina social y preventiva de la
universidad de berna doctor muchas
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
como como cada miércoles cuéntenos
bolsonaro optó por dejar circular el
virus como con la esperanza con el
objetivo de que sea si se lograra una
inmunidad colectiva porque una
estrategia así no funciona contra el
commit 19
zimmer antes de responderte la pregunta
pongamos en contexto que brasil tiene
más de 600.000 muertes es uno de los
países más afectados por la pandemia y
en la comisión del senado lo que está
acusando a funcionarios de nueve delitos
entre los que incluye charlatanismo
crimen crímenes contra la humanidad
ineptitud etcétera y los ha presentado
ante la procaduría y ante la corte
internacional de la haya desde el
principio de la pandemia vimos varios
estados no solamente brasil sino también
el reino unido suecia de los países
bajos que pensaron que una buena
estrategia sería dejar circular el virus
para producir la inmunidad colectiva y
que esto protegería a los demás muy
pronto cuando vieron las consecuencias
de este tipo de estrategias países como
el reino unido- las abandonó sin embargo
bolsonaro continuó con ellas y vimos lo
que ocurrió en manaus que fue la primera
ciudad en el mundo que se cree que
alcanzó la unidad colectiva y que pagó
un precio enorme con muchísimos muertos
muchísimos hospitales hospitalizados
colapso del sistema de salud y que ocho
meses después a principios de este año
volvió a vivir una situación similar
cuando pensaban que tenían inmunidad
colectiva entonces yo creo que la
inmunidad colectiva se está demostrando
que dejarla ocurrir por infección y no
por vacunación no es una estrategia
buena y eso de eso nos dimos cuenta ya
desde el principio del 2020 22 lo saludo
muy buen día para ustedes ya buenas
tardes allá en suiza cuando hablamos del
presidente evolucionario y también de la
pandemia se nos viene una palabra a la
cabeza es la hidroxi cloroquina porque
el presidente recomendó su uso en varias
ocasiones qué significa esta
recomendación de este medicamento y
además que este medicamento
es un medicamento que conocemos desde
hace muchos años que se utiliza para
prevenir y tratar la malaria el lupus la
artritis reumatoidea y que algunos
pacientes las necesitan entre realmente
la requieren porque funciona para estas
enfermedades para el cob y 19 vimos
líderes mundiales no solamente como
bolsonaro sino también el presidente
trump que decían que quizás este
medicamento sería una buena solución
pero realmente no teníamos ningún tipo
de evidencia y aún no tenemos evidencia
de que sea efectiva es barata se puede
distribuir porque existía sin embargo lo
que vimos es que la cantidad de
hidróxido quina que teníamos en el
mercado colapsó y no solamente no
funciona contra el kobe 19 sino las
personas que realmente la necesitaban
que no la podían conseguir
no solo la recomiendo sino que de hecho
recordemos que difundieron vídeos usando
el presidente- bolsonaro cuando el mismo
se contagió de kobe 19 usándola hidroxi
cloroquina pero no es el único
medicamento así medio sospechoso que ha
recomendado también la ivermectina que
efectivamente se ha demostrado que
tampoco ayuda contra el cob y yo quería
preguntarle si estos dos medicamentos
empeoran la situación cuando uno está
contagiado de covite se los toma o
simplemente no tienen efectos sobre
sobre la enfermedad
si no es solamente no tienen efectos
sino que si pueden empeorar la situación
en primer lugar porque hay una falsa
confianza a las personas pueden pensar
que están recibiendo algo que va a
servir y pueden no ir al hospital o
buscar la atención médica porque creen
que están recibiendo un tratamiento
adecuado en segundo lugar estos
medicamentos puede ser tóxico la hidroxi
cloroquina puede producir efectos
adversos como la diarrea vómito pero
también problemas muy serios como
problemas cardíacos que pueden generar
la muerte así que dar falsas
recomendaciones acerca de medicamentos
que no tienen pruebas que realmente no
sirven no solamente pone en riesgo a la
población sino también es una muy mala
inversión en términos de los recursos de
salud que son tan limitados en países
como brasil o en países en todo el mundo
ahora doctor también jair bolsonaro
afirma que las vacunas son
experimentales le pregunto la rapidez
con que se desarrollaron estas vacunas
es realmente un motivo de desconfianza
no realmente lo que hemos visto es que
la la rapidez y el éxito que tuvimos que
tuvo la comunidad científica en general
en contra de estas vacunas fue el
resultado de años y años de
investigación algunos dicen estas vacas
estas vacunas de rn a por ejemplo son
nuevas sin embargo llevamos más de 30
años en que la comunidad científica las
estaban investigando
simplemente requerían una mayor
inversión una mayor dedicación y durante
este periodo que tan intensa inversión
no solamente en recursos sino también en
esfuerzos científicos se pudo
desarrollar esa tecnología y se pudo
llevar al mercado en un tiempo récord
entonces para los que piensan que esto
es simplemente algo nuevo que se inventó
en el último año pues realmente no es
así porque está basado en décadas y
décadas de investigación
y hablando de vacunas precisamente
queríamos hablar de una de las últimas
noticias pandémicas también que tenemos
que estar pendientes que sucedió ayer y
es que el panel de expertos de la sda
recomendó que se aprobara el uso de la
vacuna de facer en niños y niñas de 5 a
11 años hemos hablado varias veces de
este tema aquí pero nunca está de más ir
ir acumulando también todos estos datos
que tenemos sobre esos mismos datos que
se sabe que existen quería preguntarle
si definitivamente es recomendable si o
no
vacunar a esta franja de edad con la
vacuna de facer
si tenemos que confiar en las entidades
reguladoras porque ellos toman toda la
evidencia que existe acerca de los
beneficios y los riesgos y al final la
decisión se tiene que tomar poniendo
todo esto en balanza en que cuáles son
los riesgos para el individuo y cuáles
pueden ser los beneficios si la rda está
recomendando estas vacunas para los
niños en ese rango de edad
en mi opinión yo seguiría esa
recomendación porque confío en que los
procesos y los detalles que sigue la
enfermedad como una entidad seria de
regulación y de evaluación de
medicamentos están siendo desarrollados
de una manera adecuada entonces yo creo
que siguiendo las recomendaciones de la
rda yo que tengo un hijo de siete años
podré procedería a vacunarlos y
recomendaría lo mismo para los padres
que lo están dudando si vacunar o no a
los niños una vez estén las
recomendaciones es bueno seguir las
doctor muchísimas gracias gracias por
estar nuevamente aquí con nosotros en
salud de directo américa también marc
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información y esta introducción al
doctor nos vemos en la próxima semana
con más salud y con ustedes doctor